um well hello everyone sorry for the
delay it seems like some things haven't
changed
between the pandemics like the
mac users are still annoying everyone
with their non-compatible laptops
so let's get started
to this talk we'll talk about white
rabbits flamingo and also
you know best architectural practices
and how isolating your input outputs can
help you create a more sustainable
robust and easy to
maintain code base
is this working
no
okay this is working
uh so if you're worried about me um
sergio gerard uh i've been working in
machine learning and data science for
almost uh 10 years now
i'm currently working at hokkaido and
if i was to be a bit tongue-in-cheek i
would say my job is trying to deploy
much another machine learning models
into production
that's not to say that everything that
happened before is easy or not important
but i consider that really the end goal
is to have something
deployed in production so you can make
an impact on the real world
i have a github if you want to join me
and before we start
a very small disclaimer so this talk
might or might not be be very loosely
inspired by alice's adventure in
wonderland
uh but yeah my deepest ideologies to all
lewis carl's fans in the audience if
i've misconstrued your favorite
character or something
[Music]
so
let's like with a little story it might
seem familiar to some of you
it was supposed to be like this really
easy thing you want to to fix and then
you ended up spending most of the time
trying to do it because you make a small
change here things breaks on the other
side and then again and every time you
run your test suite it runs forever
and so it's the end of day you're
getting tired
your test street has been running for
maybe i don't know 24 25 26 minutes
and yeah maybe you're dozing off a
little bit
uh feeling very sleepy
and suddenly you jerk away you you're
really sure you've seen something out of
your corner of your eyes you're like you
look and
what do you see
a little rabbit
how is it possible so you're intrigued
you follow the little mammal say okay
and you feel that the ground is
disappearing under you and you are
falling and falling
into the rabbit hole
and
yeah you're like okay so this is a time
for deep introspection you know when
you're falling in a rabbit hole at the
end of a hard day of work
and so you're thinking okay this how
does this all started
so this started with this kind of
innocuous looking little script
so what does it does at first well you
are loading stuff pandas that read csv
i'm pretty sure everyone is familiar
with that
uh yeah isolating like the features and
the labels
then you want to to scale your feature
because you know badly conditioned
metrics they can make numeric solver
very slow so
you don't want that
your training a classifier is a logistic
regression could be something else
and then you want to evaluate how well
you did on um
by computing the confusion matrix
so it seems pretty innocuous and it was
working fine but then you say okay i
want to make it more
repeatable i want to meet it's to be
able to extend that in the future so i
want to package that a little bit so
let's just write a couple of functions
to try to uh make that most sustainable
in the future
uh so you're gonna write
so three functions for each step so one
for the standardization step you say
okay my data here in this input file i'm
gonna load it scale it save a parameter
and all is good and you just do the same
thing for training part and the
evaluation part
so i don't know if the code is really
readable at the end of the room but
basically it's just you know
instantiate a classifier fit it return
it
dump it to the i to the addix sorry and
same evaluate take all the things
compute the confusion matrix print it
[Music]
and if we go to
have the equivalent of your script
before you write your main function to
link them all together and so this link
function is just like okay i've got one
step it's standardizing right nicer
that's a pre-processing step
i've got a training step and i've got an
evaluation step
so it seems that it's all good you know
each function is doing one thing very
clean very readable code
uh
yeah
there is one tiny problem here
most especially in these two lines
so this function the standardized
function
is chewing ios so you read input at the
beginning and you dump output
so the parameters of your
standardization
scalar at the end
and ios in function make functions
harder to test and tests run slower why
is that well for one thing
if you want to test
a couple cases or maybe more because
you've got some edge cases every time
you're gonna have to create
another csv file so it makes your test
less readable because you have to have
both the test and the csv file open to
understand what's happening
and it's also a bit tedious and then all
of this multi csv file adding up in your
github repository they'll end up being
quite a large chunk
of memory and so it makes all of your
repo so lower and so on and so on
because you've got outputs it means that
you have to have
after each
unit test some tear down step removing
all of your outputs to ensure that
you're not leaving anything in
on the hard drive after you run your
test and because of all of that it's
kind of easy
um
to break the test isolation principle so
that's the idea that each test should
run the same if you run only one of it
or if you run the world test suite
it's very easy to have
one test dumping things
in a file and like you forgot to tear
down properly or there is like the test
fail and the turret on step did not
execute
and then it's gonna interfere with the
input on off another test so it's very
easy to get flaky test to it
uh
and
also because you keep doing uh
calls to your hard drive it makes your
wall test list slower
and if you have a lot of unit tests like
that it adds up and you ended up with
this like 25 minutes
test suite we had at the beginning
so
yeah that might be part of your problem
you're thinking as you are falling down
this hole maybe that's why uh
this
small easy fix took me all day
well as you are amusing about that you
finally reach the bottom of the
and here you find a small table
there is a bottle on the table the
bottle has a label the label says okay
drink me
and you'll read everything but you'll
learn sorry step back you'll learn
everything about pure functions
uh so you're like okay uh you know it's
a very long day i would rather have a
beer than this weird
awareness drink but you know you take
what you have you kind of drink a large
gulp out of it
and things start spinning again like
everything is growing bigger or maybe
you're going
smaller but
at the same times you start
learning things about what pure
functions are
so what are your functions so pure
functions are functions in a
mathematical sense so not in a their
programming concept but they are the
same they have the same definition as a
mathematical function but just to say
the output
is deterministically dependent only on
the input
so this characteristic
is really comes with like great
properties they are really easy to unit
test because every time you give a
certain input for function it will spit
out the same output
so
it's easy to test all of your edge cases
because of that they're also really
great if you ever need to paralyze
anything
by design you cannot have anything like
rest condition
if you are only using pure functions so
that makes you basically get
paralyzation for free
they got a small caveat there is no side
effect so that means you cannot have any
state
in this function
but you're thinking okay
if i've got like this lightning fast
test suite with a very good coverage and
very robust
code base because i've got very high
coverage and if i ever need
parallelization i can get it for free
okay i can't i'm okay with not having
any side effects
but then under the table
yeah because you definitely grew tiny
and that's the table grow bigger
but
under the table you find this small cake
and it says it's me and on the other
side of it you say okay all i use so all
input outputs are side effects and then
you're like huh
that's a problem because i want my code
to actually do things so that means i
need to get data from my hard drive or
for an external api i need to get data
in
and once i've computed something i need
to be able to save my model somewhere i
need to be able to return prediction to
the database
so i need to make i to to make a lot of
ios so input about in order to for my
code to do anything
uh so you're like wondering huh how can
we have both the advantages of using uh
um
functions for functions
uh and still like do stuff in the real
world
so you're thinking about that you see
this tiny little door like okay let's
proceed forward and maybe a quick walk
will help me clear my mind and find
ideas
and on the other side of the door you
find a very um
friendly caterpillar with like oh you
seem worried what are you worrying about
so you explain to the caterpillar yeah
you know i would like to use pure
functions but i also want my code to be
able to do things uh with
input outputs like put things on the
hard drive read from external apis
and the catapult says oh
maybe
have you heard about the onion
architecture
so onions for computer scientists they
are like trees for computer scientists
but is to say
quite simplistic they've got
two layers
this goes
and so the idea is that you'll put all
of your ios
as
up as far up high on the abstraction on
the
codebase as possible so it's going to be
like the first thing you do and the last
thing you do in your code is the outer
layer
of
your code base
and all of the stuff
all the code that's actually the
computation that's all your business
logic all the things you really care
about and want to have foreign unit
tested
it's going to be into this
functional core so all of that is going
to be pure function
let's see an example
so i've taken again the same three
things we've seen from the initial
script i've got standardized data here
and now it's rewritten as a pure
function
so i take some data frame pandas data
frame already instantiated i create a
scalar from psychic lens
library
and i will fit the scalar and
i will return the parameters of a scalar
and the scaled data
and as you see
given that the scalar understand the
deterministic
every time i give the same input i'll
get the same output
and i've got no size effects
we can do the same for the training part
i'm giving some data already
preprocessed labels i'm instantiating a
cyclone object again
logistic regression is deterministic if
i want to use
something which is not like anything
using gradient descent i'll have to set
the random seed to ensure that the
output is deterministic
and then i can
fit my classifier with object and return
it
and same for the evaluation part
and now you say okay that's all good i'm
only acting on object in memory but how
does all this thing get into the memory
that's uh what we are doing with our
main which is our outer layer we were
talking about
so main is going to do some input so
load all of the csv
data set into pandas data frame
it's also going to load it can loads
like binary files like so the pixel of
the model
and
the
the scaling part the pre-processing part
if we want to do the evaluations
separately from
the script
and then the main is also responsible
for the outputs so when i get the
preprocessing parameters i save them to
a csv file
and save the model and also
it's responsible for printing the
confusion metrics so printing things to
std out is also an output it's a solid
side effect
and um yeah so say okay that's really
good but there are two things you
haven't talked about this load data and
load scaler function
aren't they doing some inputs and the
answer is yes yes they are doing some
inputs
ios
so the load data is just like
a
wrap around read csv and like
basically turple unpacking to split
between labels and the rest of the
columns
and
as you can see this function is mostly
it's boilerplate code so you want to
package that because you don't want to
repeat yourself everywhere in the code
but
i mean you transponders to be fairly
unit tested so you don't have to to
write so much unit test for this code
you just can write some integration test
once to check that it's passed this
through but you have to have a lot of
text on that
and lot scaler is a bit longer but it's
still mostly just unpacking values and
like storing them into this standard
scalar object so it's not doing any
actual computation again it's just
bowler plate code
and if we go back to our initial
diagrams
so we've got the main function which is
in the
imperative outer shell
and the load data and lotscaler which
are two helper functions not doing any
uh kind of
actual computation
and all the things we really care about
which is how we standardize and
that can be again more pre-processing of
the data uh what kind of algorithm do we
train on that and how do we evaluate
that this is encoded as pure functions
so this i can unit test as much as i
want very easily
oh wow
that's great
so now you're pretty confident that this
is going to help you with your current
code base
and so you thanks a lot the caterpillar
for
its help and you're like okay
sure let's start
you know improving all of that with this
on your interior sector principle
that's until you know you get to this
point which is a bit like a matchy party
and you're like okay i've got this piece
of code and i'm really not sure about
fitting in it to the onion architecture
is the right thing to do or maybe not
the only thing to do because
it's a bit weird
what are we talking about
now instead of printing the confusion
matrix to the std out you want to do
something a bit more involved you want
to save it into a google spreadsheet to
be able to share it
with other people in your team
and what's more
you've been uh evaluating on very basic
data sets so you are spreading the load
of our several instances and so you need
to be able to get the current
yeah the current
content of the confusion matrix
and
like add the new data point you have to
it so that you get the new confusion
matrix so confusion matrix is basically
the thing computing you've got false
positive and true positive false
negative and true negative so you can
just add them if you've got several
batches of data and get the uh
the global thing out of it
so you can see there are in this
function you've got some things which
are around authentications to be able to
access
the google api
then you are basically opening a
spreadsheet
then a given tab in this spreadsheet and
then you are doing what you actually
care about that is to say
getting the current state of the
confusion matrix
updating it so here our
computation is an addition you can
imagine it's like a 200 lines
uh function
instead
and
then we are
basically dumping the new content into
the same
worksheet so in the same tab of a
spreadsheet
okay so
this is the function doing a lot of ios
let's try to put it into a onion
architecture
style of coding
so at first
we're gonna extract the functional core
so air is very short so once this gain
is just additioning to
confusion mattresses
so okay we'll not talk more about that
the interesting part is the overpart
which is okay the
loading and then the saving part of this
confusion matrices
metric sorry and you can see at first
but well there are
a lot of code repeating itself in the
two function
and the only really
thing differing is the last line in one
case you do a worksheet.get
another guess you do a worksheet.update
um but okay
let's for now you know there's this rule
like if it's you're repeating yourself
twice it's probably okay if you're
repeating yourself free time you need to
factorize it so okay it's only two times
we're probably fine
uh
and yeah
and so uh now
our main function is looking like that
so you load the confusion matrix update
it
save it
good that's on your architecture
this is a pure function i can unit test
this is boilerplate code i don't need to
unit test i will just test it with
integration test
all good
yeah
sorry i forgot i had that
okay
let's have a deeper look about the
loading function
so there are a lot of things here which
feels like you know you don't really
care about that there are things that
are required by this jspreads
third-party libraries to interact with
google api
but you
like it really feels like if your own
code is deeply intertwined with this
jspread third party library
and it kind of feels a bit clunky
because
well for one thing when you are testing
you probably don't want to have to
set up credentials to access google api
every time there are you know things
around rate limiting is you don't want
you to access that again and again
so you're probably gonna end up using
like something like mock but mock can
get really really messy more uh
they're hard to write they are hard to
read they are harder to maintain
so you know
i'm not big proponents of mark so i try
to use them as little possible so this
is kind of
i don't really like that
and also if like the
spread library is changing uh his api at
some point in time
then you'll have to rewrite all of your
code because it's so deeply intertwined
with the jsp the api it's gonna make it
hard to to understand where the
why are you impacted by this change so
it makes updating uh third party
libraries complex
so
you know we can probably do better
so again
we're back to this thing and what we
really care about is this line like i
want to get
the data which is in the b4
sorry b2 d4 area i don't want anything
else so okay let's extract that
put it into its own little function
and same thing here okay when we are
saving we're just updating
and
this is our new main
so we are loading
updating saving same as before except
uh is it really the same as before so
instead of taking the name i'm sorry red
black is really not readable but
instead of taking the name of the
worksheet we want to open we're actually
now taking a worksheet object directly
and this worksheet object is created
by this
openg worksheet function
and she
this function is taking care of the all
of the um authorization shenanigans and
the details on how the uh
spread library is really working so if
uh g-spread was to make any changes in
the future you only have to change this
function
uh about our authorization work also so
it's um
it's better
and so
again
this is flickering
okay
um
so it's blinking you see when you are
testing the only thing you need to do is
uh you don't have to use actual marks
you can do uh with uh having some uh
you know
um
test double so just create an object and
say okay it has to implement a get and
an update
method
and then
it will
it will be better so it's
it's an improvement and it's called is
this
doing the same thing again
yes
do i get to restart it
yeah okay
um
can i get my speaker not again or not
just try that
and i lost the other one
yep
so this is the principle it's called
dependency injection so the idea is that
your code should not be uh responsible
for instantiating
any of the third parties object you are
using it to receive it from the outside
so it here it receive it um
uh
it receives
from
the main this open j worksheet is
responsible for creating the for
creating the worksheet object and
[Music]
and giving it to your uh other functions
so it's already much better for testing
and also like for robustness to future
change uh due to third parties api
uh there's still something a bit
bothering me though
it's this
uh a rear parameter
it's kind of
oddly specific to what you are doing
with
google apis uh it wouldn't make any
sense if you are using for example a
local csv or something
um and so
we can take this dependency injection
one step further and try to do something
which is using abstraction layer
so abstraction layer will define a
contract of what you will expect from
the outside world
and then
your you'll get an object
which is instantiated to respect that
contract
so in this ide what we want is basically
we want a spreadsheet or worksheet
object and it has to have two things you
can want to be able to load data out of
it and we want to be able to dump data
in it
and so i could write it like that so
this is a
a
spreadsheet object and so you see that
in the in it i had all of the uh
authentication shenanigans i had before
and also this uh self dot area principle
uh sorry
yeah so all the shenanigans i had before
i have the things like around how do i
open a given tab
which can change in the future but i
just have to change it here and there is
this area attribute which is
used only by this
type of
spreadsheet
and then my load and my dump are again
they basically take
they return an amp array for the load
and they take the numpy array for the
dump and they save it and they do all
that they need to do to get it saved in
the spreadsheet
and uh yeah so
it might be a bit confusing but the
exact difference between just dependency
understand using an abstraction layer is
uh independency ejection or load and
save confusion matrix functions they are
dependent on the things which are
required by
the third party api here it needs an
area
of data to load
or to where to them to
here i just have a load and dump and
it's really agnostic to my third-party
dependencies
and so if i want to use something else
than google api so maybe i want to use
uh store things in the spreadsheet only
in production but when i am developing i
just want to store it to a
local excel file or maybe
i want to use a local xl5 when i'm doing
some
local tests you know and i don't want to
instantiate all of this uh
authorization clients during testing
and so i can just write another function
so is this
excel spreadsheet
and
so you see that the init is very
different
and also there are the load and the dump
function are not the same but they are
also returning uh an amp array so using
pandas red excel and then using dot
values to get the numpy arrays out of it
and on the other end they're taking a
also an amp arrays instantiating a data
frame to use again the pandas
capabilities to work with excel but all
of this
your end user or that is to say
the you not writing vios your co-workers
or your the future you in two months
they don't care about these details they
just say okay i can load and things into
an excel file
so how can we show that both of these
classes we developed are actually
the same implementing the same
abstraction they are the same api so the
object-oriented
language you typically use uh class
inheritance to do that so have an
abstract class we'll have just a load
and a dump method and say okay a
raise not implemented error in here and
so you'll have to subclass this abstract
class to get it working there's actually
a better way of doing vast in python
that is more respectful of
what we call duck typing so
the idea of duct typing if if it quacks
like a duck and if it's swim like a duck
and if you walk like a duck then it's a
duck
uh that's the idea that if you've got
any object you can iterate upon so any
object instantiating the dunder eater
function you don't have to have it
explicitly subclass
the iterable abstract class
and so since python 3.8 and before if
you are using my pi you can use
something called protocol which is
saying okay
my load function
returns an npra my dumb function takes
an amp array and basically my main
function you have to have managed to
instantiate a spreadsheet at some point
uh to make it work
good
uh so you're okay maybe a bit
overwhelmed by all of this information
uh but you're nimbling your score you
know you you are sitting for tea
grabbing a tipper to get
and then in the chipper what you have
a little dorm house and you say okay
that's really cool but you know remember
that uh
using the bad section it's really really
costly
so in this very simple cases load dump
it's kind of easy to see what the right
abstraction is but in some other cases
it can be much harder
so it's already worth taking quite a lot
of time to to to determine if the
abstraction is the right one when you
find the right way you should feel quite
intuitive in a sense
um
and yeah
there is this thing around the end of my
phone you say if the implantation is
easy to explain it's maybe a good idea
so there's this idea that it should be
kind of natural
that this is the right abstraction to
use
okay
now let's go to a party of the queen
crockett after the tea party
and i don't know if you know but queen
crockett our play is played with uh
flamingo and hedgehogs and so
that's kind of how it feels when you get
to some other more complex
codes architectural needs
when things are like really not behaving
the way they should
so quite quickly uh because a bit short
on time uh the idea we had so far was
basically load do stuff and dump and we
would do stuff but do not not including
any ios but in real life you've got
things like you've got a long
computation and you want to be able to
get regular logging things on what's
happening
uh you're doing a very long training and
you want to be able to save checkpoints
to restart your training in the middle
if anything goes bad
or you've got in a workflow and for
example you are caching this very long
computation so you have to access the db
to know how long ago this computation
was made before deciding if you want to
make it or not
so these are things happening um
it's worth mentioning that
as much as possible
you should try to stick to this
initial
load do dump
structure as long as you scan so as long
as you don't have any major performance
issues or cost issues because it's
really really uh easier
but when it does not work we can have a
look at how python is doing it with the
implementation of logging in the
standard library
and so a logo is basically something
which is taking
as input a string
and it's responsible for us for for
doing something with a string so it
might display it in
debug mode and displayed in production
environment and so on
and so the logger is from the standard
library so it knows nothing about your
own application code
and your application is just sending
things to the logger and it does not
rely on the logger to do anything for it
afterwards
and so you should try to have the same
id when you have like saving checkpoints
in uh training or something
uh
create something which behaves like a
logger it should be agnostic to what
your application is actually doing and
your application should not be dependent
on it
um
[Music]
yes so
you it looks like you're in winning this
game of croquettes and the queen of
hearts is getting very annoyed with that
uh and so she's screaming
and you're like okay this is not going
good
and you start running because you're
feeling very afraid
and you remind all the things you've
learned into this wonderland one thing
is
uh
sorry i'm going to skip that
one thing is that um ios should occur at
the
highest level possible so first thing
and last thing in your code then you
should try to inject dependencies so
that your code is agnostic to
third-party dependencies
and try to use abstraction layer
but the most important thing of all is
as the zen of python is saying
practicality beats purity
oh well
suddenly you jerk awake and you're like
okay i'm probably going to be able to
merge with merge requests i'm almost not
late at all
and then okay you definitely forgot to
commit before
push forcing again
wow
i think there won't be any time for
question i just wanted to give a quick
shout out to my co-worker sophie who
made the wonderful illustration
and you akim will help me with the
nitty-gritty details of the css and i'll
be taking any questions outside i guess
[Applause]